didn't your parents like say to you we
don't care how you do in school we just
like dude just uh have make do creative
things every day no they were they did
not they did not plus I was the youngest
of six too so by the time they were
tired
had enough of this parenting yeah do you
mean you go out to Hollywood and the
first gig you get is yeah no the first
the first gig I got was I was at acting
school and uh the casting director from
Animal House comes by wow and I didn't
have an agent or anything oh my God and
um yeah it was it was it was amazing
what do you mean you just watched you in
acting school he just came by acting
school and said uh you know we're
looking for these like kind of fresh
College freshman types do you have
anybody and they sent me over and uh I
made a face basically because there were
not that many lines I didn't really have
that many lines but John Landis said I
want you to be smarmy and I literally
had no idea what that word smarmy meant
so but it was it's kind of like what do
you call that a onomatopoeia it's it's
like it's something that sounds like
this is what it is so I made this
special murky I was like yeah like I
made a face that I thought you know and
he's like that's it that's smart me I
love that
guy you know and now and uh so I came
came back and they flew me out to uh
they flew me out to Oregon and they
never had to be the biggest thing in
your life okay let me tell you I mean
you're insane okay so they called me up
was everyone in your acting class
completely jealous uh
um I don't know I had to be maybe yeah
most of those guys go to acting school
and then nobody comes buying hires well
I went back to acting school after I'd
finished a movie and I thought I was
like a big star and stuff and and
literally I had to go back and ask for
my my waiting tables job at back when
the movie came out I was waiting tables
and um did you go to the premiere oh
[ __ ] what a story
so like the premiere is coming so I
asked him for the night off from work
and uh I get all excited about it you
know because I'm going to my movie and
my movie and it's the premiere and stuff
like that so I take the subway down it's
in Times Square and I get out and here's
the red carpet and all the people and
the things but I'm on the other side of
the red car okay dude get out the
[ __ ] record and the limos start
pulling out and here goes all the Animal
House guys right and they are all
[ __ ] been flown out here from LA and
they got limos and [ __ ] and I don't even
have the goods I'm looking I'm like in
this [ __ ] season I I see one of the guys
recognizes me like takes pity on me and
lets me through the you know through the
red carpet the girls are really
impressed with that and uh and and he
takes me into uh into this into the
theater and like the security guard
stops me and says oh what color check it
do you have uh uh I'll get back there
you know
so uh uh humiliating this humiliating I
I I come out and they have buses to take
everybody down to the Village Gate is
where the party was and forget this
night I mean worst night of your life
worst night in my life and um so I get
down to the party and now my hair is
kind of grown
and nobody recognizes me from the movie
and I'm like trying to pull you know I'm
like hitting on these girls and I'm
saying you don't okay I'm the guy he's
like yeah whatever uh you know West
Belushi you know right and uh so I I
leave the party you're like Hollywood
Showbiz isn't so great yeah I get all
[ __ ] up and I I leave the party and I
go back to the restaurant and I hung out
with my friends
it was it was one of the most depressing
nights of my life I gotta tell you
foreign